si llegó la selección de madrugada es
una zona alejada de la ciudad es una
zona
rodeada de autopistas tal vez uno podía
esperar que le costara más a la gente
sin embargo hubo
multitudes que esperaron horas y horas y
horas para recibir y alentar a la
selección que les dio esta enorme
alegría de una tercera copa del mundo y
sobre todo por supuesto al Capitán pero
también a todo el equipo porque es un
equipo que trabajó en conjunto que
trabajó en equipo y creo que es algo que
se está empezando a celebrar aquí en
Argentina también una selección muy
unida muy homogénea que le dio esta
alegría enorme a los argentinos que
hicieron ese esfuerzo gigante de ir a
recibirlos allí como te digo en esta
zona alejada de la de la ciudad de
Buenos Aires y de zonas y de zonas
residenciales el viaje fue desde el
Aeropuerto de ezeiza como decías a un
predio de la asociación del fútbol
argentino donde jugadores luego pasaron
la noche preparándose para los festejos
de este día